they say it was amazing he won three
piston cups
it was at this point when it became
abundantly clear to me that pixar movies
are not made for kids
i mean yes they're generally seen as
family-friendly films but there are a
lot of things that just go straight over
the heads of all the kids watching
there's tons of little details that
almost every kid would miss there's
certain innuendos if you know what i
mean and there's adult themes even
exploring the concept of death but how
exactly does pixar make such great films
that appeal to kids while also making
something that adults can enjoy just as
much the answer hidden worlds
[Music]
now what exactly do i mean when i say
the phrase hidden worlds basically we
get to see worlds that may only exist in
myths or in one's imagination pixar
takes something that may seem
insignificant at first glance such as a
rat or a car and they use the device of
personification to bring those things to
life in a way that we may have never
seen or even imagined before pixar then
uses these personified objects creatures
or even spirits to create an extended
metaphor that brings forth a truth about
the real world that we may not have
recognized before take finding nemo for
example pixar takes the real-life
undersea world of fish and couples it
with a strained relationship between an
overly cautious father and an
adventurous kid they personify these
fish showing us the hidden world of sea
creatures interacting in ways we'd never
even imagined before ultimately though
the film brings forth the universal
truth that sometimes the best way to
keep the ones you love safe is to trust
them now look at toy story pixar takes
inanimate toys left behind in a child's
bedroom and brings them to life in a way
that makes just about everyone question
what their toys do behind closed doors
pixar personifies these dolls and
playthings showing us the hidden world
of toys in the end the film brings forth
the truth that we can't stop change no
matter how hard we try so we should
instead try to embrace it pixar is able
to make such great stories because
they're consistent they're consistent
with the quality of work they produce
with the amount of time their creators
invest in every movie and with the
meaningful messages each film delivers
they're simply second to none when it
comes to producing an animated feature
film and whether you think all their
movies are cinematic masterpieces or not
ultimately comes down to your own
opinion whether it's the hidden world of
monsters of emotions of sea creatures of
superhero families of bugs or the land
of the dead pixar delivers stories which
ultimately resonate with almost anyone
on a level that few other animated films
can you might be wondering though how is
pixar able to make these hidden worlds
appeal to adults rather than just to
children and the answer lies in their
film's dialogue and their little details
pixar uses a very basic writing
structure for their dialogue and plot
details a former writer for pixar emma
coats actually wrote out the structure
on twitter once upon a time there was a
blank
every day blank
one day blank
because of that blank until finally
blank this story structure was outlined
by coats along with several other rules
and what pixar calls the 22 rules of
storytelling and you can find that each
of these guidelines are more or less
followed in every pixar story some of
these rules include you admire a
character for trying more than for their
successes or come up with your ending
before you figure out your middle
seriously endings are hard get yours
working up front or discount the first
thing that comes to mind and the second
third fourth fifth get the obvious out
of the way surprise yourself and it's
probably this last rule that seems to
help push pixar towards adult focused
dialogue and writing from time to time
when writers are trying to surprise
themselves they're likely to surprise
the audience with things like one can
get too familiar with vegetables you
know
or not
she just likes me for my body it's
moments like these that truly show you
that pixar isn't just making these
movies for kids ultimately they're
hoping to make a film that anyone can
enjoy including adults and they're able
to do this because pixar's writers have
total creative freedom with little to no
oversight this in turn attracts the top
talent in the animation industry and
they're able to come up with some of the
greatest stories and animation of all
time but just how do pixar's film stand
out from the crowd the little details
and pixar actually has an entire
department devoted to the little details
this team doing what pixar calls shading
focuses on adding all the dirt rust
bumps scratches and other surface
textures to objects that initially
appear smooth and lifeless when they
come out of the computer these are the
kind of details that children likely
wouldn't notice much at all but that
adults can see and understand the extra
effort it takes to bring this realism to
an animated picture things like the cuts
and burns on the chef's hands in
ratatouille or the dust kicked up by the
toys when they run by in toy story just
end up being the icing on the cake in an
already revolutionary creative process
pixar's shading and lighting departments
are constantly innovating to find better
ways to add these little details such as
when their teams created ai-powered
spiders to spin lifelike cobwebs in the
antique store and toy story 4. this type
of innovation isn't new for pixar either
they were actually the ones to first
invent 3d animation when they created
the first feature-length 3d animated
film with toy story not only did they
invent 3d animation though but they also
revolutionized the way animation studios
film their scenes pixar actually uses
virtual camera rigs to set the blocking
and shots for their scenes in much the
same way that live action films do they
first build the characters and place
them in the set for any given scene and
then they place a fake camera inside the
set to film the animation as it takes
place at any other studio a process like
this likely wouldn't have been possible
with pixar though there's almost no
friction between business and art
because the technical staff is also the
creative staff they work hand in hand to
create the most innovative animation
processes possible delivering films at
such a quality that adults can enjoy
even more so than kids pixar's films are
not pure fantasy they're not simply
fictitious stories with little to no
basis in reality like movies you might
see studios such as dreamworks or
illumination produce that only appeal to
kids instead pixar's films find the
magic within our reality and make that
magic a reality on screen they show us
hidden worlds in far-off places that we
could never imagine on our own and that
we can enjoy just as much as children
they bring realism and universal truths
to the forefront of our minds but most
of all pixar creates a new world for us
to see a world which we'll continue to
think about anytime we leave our toys
behind closed doors
anyways that's going to be all for today
if you like what you saw maybe check out
the video on your screen for some
different content i make videos on
basically anything that interests me in
the world of entertainment also don't
forget to like and subscribe as it truly
does help me out and thanks for watching
rocketriley